président de la république a nommé
monsieur edouard philippe premier
ministre et l'a chargé de former le
nouveau gouvernement
je vous remercie avec emmanuel macron la
nomination d'un premier ministre est
souvent une affaire de suspect
[Musique]
le 15 mai 2010 est le tout nouveau
président emmanuel macron doit rendre
public le nom de son premier ministre
'l'annonce doit être faite le matin même
la rumeur edouard philippe circule le
locataire socialiste de matignon bernard
cazeneuve est même prêt pour la
passation de pouvoir mais finalement ça
s'annonce plus long près 10 heures alors
que des camions de déménagement vont et
viennent devant l'hôtel de matignon
bernard cazeneuve se promène tout
sourire dans la tente de son départ vous
savez à quelle heure vous quitter
matignon
une demi heure plus tard la garde
républicaine est le convoi du premier
ministre quitte les lieux
signe d'une annonce retarder les
journalistes se lance alors à la
poursuite du taxi d'edouard philippe qui
rejoint son bureau à l'assemblée
nationale et dans l'après midi
'l'annonce tombe enfin mais attention
c'est très bref président de la
république a nommé monsieur edouard
philippe premier ministre et l'a chargé
de former le nouveau gouvernement
je vous remercie juste quelques secondes
après des heures d'attentes vient
ensuite le moment de la passation de
pouvoir entre un premier ministre de
gauche et un premier ministre issu de la
droite je quitte la responsabilité qui
est la mienne en homme de gauche
avec mes convictions
avec les valeurs qui ont été forgés tout
au long d'une éducation et d'une
expérience politique la loyauté la
fidélité
le respect de ceux qui on en crée des
courants de pensée dans l'histoire ont
constitué une boussole vous avez dit que
vous étiez un homme de gauche
je n'avais pas non plus de doute là
dessus
il se trouve que je suis moi-même un
homme de droite
ce qui ne vous surprendra pas je le sais
et pourtant et pourtant comme vous je
sais que alors même que vous êtes un
homme de gauche et que je suis un homme
de droite nous avons l'un pour l'autre
de l'estiment emmanuel macron a donc
choisi un membre du parti les
républicains pour diriger son
gouvernement avec un objectif entraîner
une vague de recrues venues de la droite
et au sein du parti et l'air les
divisions commence entre d'un côté ceux
qui sont prêts à travailler avec la
future majorité en marche c'est le cas
d'alain juppé qui est d'ailleurs le
mentor d'edouard philippe et de l'autre
côté les l'air qui prône l'indépendance
de leur parti et minimise les effets
d'une telle nomination si la droite et
le centre de sont pas majoritaires à
l'assemblée nationale
je paye ne comprendrais pas que de nous
engagions dans une opposition
systématique
il faudra alors trouver les voies et
moyens d'un travail constructif dans
l'intérêt de la france je crains que en
dehors de ceux qui vont rentrer au
gouvernement demain et du premier
ministre en dehors des 4 5 donc personne
de droit tant que tout qui d'une manière
ou d'une autre or ont rejoint le
gouvernement les autres bougent pas et
feront la campagne et les rues des cinq
ans plus tard on peut quand même dire
que de nombreux cadres du parti
républicain ont migré vers la macro nier
en tout cas pour ce nouveau quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron le prochain premier
ministre ne sera pas forcément de droite
il sera le site attaché aux questions
sociales et à la protection de
l'environnement c'est ce qui est déjà
annoncé emmanuel macron
[Musique]